[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica siete días un
magazine informativo dedicado a áfrica
comenzamos con los titulares en somalia
el ex jefe de estado hassan sheikh
mahmud fue elegido presidente por
segunda vez mahmud se impuso frente al
presidente saliente mohamed farmajo
madrid y rabat reabre en los pasos
fronterizos entre el norte de marruecos
y ceuta y melilla los enclaves españoles
en el norte de áfrica tenemos un informe
de nuestra corresponsal y conocemos a
dos afro caribeños que regresaron a
bening en busca de su historia como lo
hacen cada vez más afrodescendientes un
reportaje imprescindible quédense con
nosotros
tras unas elecciones maratónicas y bajo
fuertes medidas de seguridad somalia
eligió a hasan mahmud como presidente
por segunda vez
mahmud que fue jefe de estado entre 2012
y 2017 se impuso frente al presidente
saliente mohammed abdullah mohammed
conocido como farmajo
pensemos en el mañana no en el ayer y en
lo que pasó trabajaré por un futuro
brillante y hermoso para que mi pueblo
viva con dignidad en el mundo aplicaré
mi lema 'con mal en paz consigo misma y
con el mundo
[Música]
son varios los retos del nuevo
presidente uno de ellos es la economía
el 71% de la población vive con menos de
1.90 dólares al día mientras el país
atraviesa una de las peores sequías en
décadas desde hace más de un año parte
de la comunidad internacional
insistía para que se organizaran
elecciones alegando que los retrasos
distraían a las autoridades de la lucha
contra el grupo al shabab que lleva 15
años activo en el país en los últimos
meses al shabab ha intensificado sus
ataques el 24 de marzo un doble atentado
en el centro de somalia causó 48 muertos
seguido de un ataque contra una base de
las fuerzas de la unión africana
justamente para luchar contra este grupo
terrorista el presidente de eeuu joe
biden autorizó volver a desplegar tropas
estadounidenses en somalia el ex
presidente de trump había ordenado su
retirada en 2020
el domingo mal y anunció su retirada de
la organización g5 sahel
bamako justifica la salida como protesta
ante la negativa de los otros países
miembros a quemar y presida la mente la
entidad el gobierno valiente acusa a
francia de estar detrás de la campaña en
su contra escuchemos al portavoz de la
junta militar de mali
la posición de
la oposición de algunos estados del g 5
de liza ger a la presidencia de malí
está relacionada con las maniobras de un
estado extranjero nal que busca
desesperadamente aislar a nuestro país
mal y de esta situación el gobierno de
la república de malí no reduce una
pérdida de autonomía del importe de
autonomía una instrumentalización y dos
grave de difusión de las instancias 1010
5 sahel de sordo news es en saber aunque
seconds en consecuencia el gobierno de
la república de malí decide retirarse de
todos los órganos y organismos del
estado sin saber
el g5 a él está conformado por
mauritania chad burkina faso y níger se
trata de un marco de cooperación para
mejorar la seguridad y el desarrollo en
la región del sahel donde se multiplican
los grupos yihadistas
pero desde el 9 de enero malí es objeto
de una serie de medidas económicas y
diplomáticas contra la intención de la
junta de permanecer en el poder a medio
plazo
los militares malienses han optado por
una transición de dos años mientras que
la comunidad económica de estados de
áfrica occidental cedeao idea bamako que
organice las elecciones en un plazo
máximo de 16 meses y francia por su
parte acusa a las autoridades malienses
de haber pedido los servicios de la
controvertida empresa privada rusa
wagner
ya es oficial españa y marruecos se
reabra en sus pasos fronterizos entre
los enclaves españoles de ceuta y
melilla y el norte del país africano el
pasado mes de abril tras la visita de
reconciliación del jefe del gobierno
español pedro sánchez a rabat ambos
países sellaron una hoja de ruta que
estipulaba entre otros puntos la
necesidad de una circulación fluida
aunque controlada de personas y
mercancías entre las dos naciones los
detalles los tiene nuestra corresponsal
en marruecos sofía catalán
si las fronteras de ceuta y melilla se
reabren tras más de dos años cerradas
debido a la pandemia y también a la ya
resuelta crisis diplomática entre españa
y marruecos pero lo cierto es que nos
encontramos ante una reapertura parcial
y prácticamente es simbólica de dichas
fronteras y es que de momento solamente
van a poder acceder a los enclaves
españoles a los ciudadanos que tengan
pasaporte europeo o una visado schengen
y para que ustedes se ubiquen aquí en la
frontera de ceuta antes del cierre a los
ciudadanos marroquíes a residentes en la
limítrofe provincia de tetuán a podían
acceder a estas ciudades españolas sin
visado schengen solamente con su
documento nacional de identidad eso sí
no podían haber no optar en el
territorio y además muchas de estas
personas tenían contrato de trabajo en
el ceuta había pues alrededor de cinco
mil personas contratadas que paso que
tras dos años de cierre pues a la
mayoría de esta gente le caducaron en
los papeles y ya no tienen el permiso de
trabajo y ahora el ministerio del
interior de españa les exige un visa
para poder volver a acceder a los
enclaves españoles y hablábamos con
estas personas nos comentaban que viven
una situación el límite en su mayoría
hace dos años que no tienen ingresos y
tampoco tienen prestaciones sociales eso
a pesar de haber estado cotizando a la
seguridad social española por otra parte
tanto las autoridades españolas como
marroquíes han reforzado a ambos lados
de la frontera los dispositivos
policiales y el gobierno de marruecos ha
anunciado la prohibición total del
contrabando y cabe recordar que las
fronteras de ceuta y melilla son las
únicas fronteras de la unión europea en
territorio africano y a la vez son las
más desiguales del mundo
y la reconciliación entre marruecos y
españa no fue del agrado de argelia país
donde se desplazó el pasado martes el
jefe de la diplomacia rusia serguéi
lávrov
además de acoger con satisfacción nuevos
acuerdos económicos de cooperación entre
ambos países lávrov mencionó también la
cuestión de la guerra en ucrania y
saludó la posición de argelia al
respecto recordemos que en marzo el país
norteafricano se había abstenido de
condenar en la onu la invasión rusa de
ucrania preguntamos a gran heart jeff
periodista argelino cuál es el interés
para argelia en el contexto actual de la
guerra en ucrania de reforzar sus
relaciones con rusia
la visita de sergei lávrov demostró que
argelia es muy importante a los ojos de
rusia para su estrategia global de apoyo
político y diplomático a sus operaciones
en ucrania
la élite
es difícil en realidad a argelia
desempeña con gran dificultad el papel
de equilibrista entre occidente y rusia
tiene un gran interés en mantener buenas
relaciones con él porque éste es su
principal proveedor de armas y lo ha
sido desde la independencia de argelia
y difícil sería muy difícil de un día
para otro cambiar de socio sobre todo si
es occidental
con argelia también se beneficia un poco
de la subida del precio del petróleo y
teme el aumento del precio del trigo y
de los fertilizantes
por eso argelia intenta cuidar su
vínculo con rusia sin embargo el país se
abstiene de apoyar la invasión a ucrania
o la
agresión hong kong
pasemos ahora a un tema completamente
diferente desde hace algunos años muchos
afrocaribeños en busca de su historia y
sus raíces se instalan en áfrica
occidental y como lo vemos en el
siguiente reportaje algunos de ellos
intentan de reencontrarse con la
tradición africana de la que fueron
apartados por el tráfico de esclavos es
un informe de manuel soy y en benin
baco es originario de guadalupe una isla
del caribe hace tres años este
treintañero lo dejó todo para instalarse
en venimos varios siglos después de que
uno de sus antepasados fuera deportados
del continente africano durante las
platas de esclavos françois kabul el
viene de martinica otra isla del caribe
para su proyecto de cómic el autor pasó
varias semanas en benin investigando la
herencia africana de los caribeños
cuya ciudad usted mucho antes de llegar
al continente stefan eligió un nombre de
áfrica occidental- bach desde entonces
ha continuado su aprendizaje en suelo
beninés lo que le interesa al afro
caribeño es esta escuela primaria donde
se enseña el currículo oficial pero
también la cultura autóctona al igual
que las virtudes de las plantas el arte
de la adivinación llamado aquí va para
abajo la reparación de la identidad es
sobre todo una cuestión de reconexión
con el vudú hoy en día lo veo mucho más
como una ciencia y una forma de vida que
forma parte totalmente de la cultura en
este sentido era importante para mí
a reconectar con los orígenes de mi
cultura poder reconectar también con
estas partes sexuales
único logotipo de una escuela de vudú
sería tan inimaginable en martinica y
guadalupe el pontífice vudú cuendo tacto
con un segundo que se enteró de la
presencia de los afrodescendientes viene
a su encuentro tuvo tu fe
quiso para ti debemos hacer todo lo
posible para que los que se fueron
involuntariamente y por la fuerza puedan
encontrar su verdadera raíz la mitad de
sus invitados dos días más tardes a una
consulta tradicional de clarividencia
françois permanece en su segundo plano
bakú iniciado en el vudú haitiano está
ya muy avanzado en el aprendizaje de la
cultura tradicional la prueba para sus
visiones en la la primera de las
reparaciones sería finalmente es recoger
el hilo donde se cortó el que nos
despojaron al deportar a nuestros
antepasados al caribe
igual
los fieles al vudú nunca han olvidado a
los africanos transportados a las
américas todos los años desde 1728
celebran rituales el 10 de enero para
festejar a sus antepasados desarraigados
y traer de vuelta a sus descendientes en
la actualidad unos 50 afro caribeños han
regresado a venir de manera definitiva
temo a el festival de música urbana de
abiyán se inauguró el 10 de mayo y se
clausuró del 15 este evento es tan
social como musical y la edición número
14 ha hecho del empleo de los jóvenes en
el continente su tema principal y es que
aunque una de las riquezas de áfrica es
su juventud ésta tiene dificultades para
encontrar su lugar en el mercado laboral
pero el festival simula es sobre todo un
festival de música la república
democrática del congo y la rumba
congoleña declarada patrimonio
inmaterial por la unesco fueron
celebrados escuchemos al comisario del
festival que habló con nuestros colegas
de france 24 en francés
hemos querido rendir un homenaje a la
república democrática del congo en
primer lugar porque es un gran país
africano y porque este país simboliza la
cultura africana en toda su diversidad
de polis
la cultura africana todo el mundo sabe
que este año la rumba congoleña ha sido
incluida en el patrimonio inmaterial de
la unesco así que es una música que
queríamos honrar es una música pionera
en aplicación y era la freak cerramos
entonces esta edición con un concierto
del festival en una hora la rumba
congoleña
gracias por seguirnos y la actualidad
continúa en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]